Nos piden resolver la ecuación,
3 más la raíz principal de "5x" más 6 es igual a 12.
Básicamente la estrategia
para resolver este tipo de ecuaciones
es dejar de un lado solo el radical,
para posteriormente elevar al cuadrado la ecuación
y deshacernos del radical,
pero hay que ser muy cuidadosos pues cuando elevamos al cuadrado perdemos información,
de que estamos tomando la raíz cuadrada principal, no la raíz cuadrada negativa,
ni más menos la raíz cuadrada,
sino la raíz cuadrada principal.
Así es que cuando obtengamos nuestra solución,
tenemos que verificar en la ecuación original
que estamos obteniendo la raíz cuadrada principal.
Veamos eso con esta ecuación.
Así es que lo primero que voy a hacer
es dejar del lado izquierdo solo este radical
y para eso me voy a deshacer de este 3,
por lo cual voy a restar 3 del lado izquierdo
y por supuesto para que no se altere la ecuación,
voy a restar 3 del lado derecho,
de otra manera perderíamos la igualdad.
¿qué tenemos entonces?
del lado izquierdo se cancela 3 y -3
nos queda tan solo la raíz cuadrada principal
de "5x" más 6,
y esto es igual a 12 menos 3,
que es igual a 9.
Vamos entonces ahora a elevar al cuadrado
para eliminar el radical,
elevamos al cuadrado del lado izquierdo
y elevamos al cuadrado el 9.
Cuando hacemos esto...
cuando hacemos esto, obtenemos "5x" más 6,
al elevar al cuadrado la raíz cuadrada de "5x" más 6,
obtenemos "5x" más 6,
y aquí es donde perdemos información,
porque también obtendríamos esto si hubiéramos elevado al cuadrado,
menos la raíz de "5x" más 6,
es por eso que tenemos que tener cuidado con las soluciones que obtengamos
y cerciorarnos que funciona cuando en la ecuación original tomamos la raíz cuadrada principal,
tenemos entonces "5x" más 6 del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho tenemos
y esta es una ecuación lineal común y corriente.
Despejamos "5x" restando 6 del lado izquierdo
y 6 del lado derecho,
6 y -6 se cancela, nos queda "5x" del lado izquierdo,
del lado derecho nos queda 81 menos 6
75.
Ahora dividimos ambos lados de la ecuación entre 5, del lado izquierdo
5 y 5 se cancelan,
nos queda "x" es igual a 75 entre 5,
esto es igual a 15,
¿Si? 5 por 10 = 50, 5 por 5 = 25,
así es que efectivamente "x" es igual a 15.
Ahora para este "x" igual a 15, tenemos
que cerciorarnos que funciona para la ecuación original.
Pudiera ser que esta es la solución
considerando menos la raíz de "5x" más 6,
verifiquemos entonces que funciona para
la raíz cuadrada principal, la raíz positiva,
sustituyendo nuestra solución en la ecuación original,
tenemos 3 por la raíz cuadrada principal de
5 por 15 = 75
más 6,
sólo sustituye el valor de 15,
en la ecuación original,
y esto tiene que ser igual a 12,
por lo cual tenemos que 3
más la raíz cuadrada principal de 81 es igual a 12.
La raíz cuadra principal de 81 es 9,
por lo cual nos queda
3 más 9 igual a 12,
12 igual a 12,
entonces tenemos la certeza
de que esta es una solución adecuada.